dans la légende des samouraïs et dans la
terminologie des samouraïs, Aronian est un samouraï
sans cause sans but Wolverine est
l'outsider ultime et dans notre film
qui se déroule après x-men 3, il est
probablement plus isolé que vous n'en avez jamais
vu plus c'est  un
personnage qui en a tellement marre de vivre et
tellement marre de son pouvoir de guérison qu'il a perdu son
sens et c'est un endroit dangereux pour
quelqu'un d'aussi puissant que Wolverine
le début de notre histoire se déroule
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale
c'est la bombe de Nagasaki est sur le point de tomber
il y a de la panique
partout où polka rencontre un jeune Yashida,
non, il finit par lui sauver la vie
quelque 60 ans plus tard, le jeune ashit est
devenu probablement l'
homme d'affaires le plus puissant du Japon.
J'essaie de vous trouver depuis plus d'un an,
mon employeur veut dire  merci de lui avoir
sauvé la vie il y a toutes ces années mais
y'a pas de surprise c'est bon de te
revoir il voit en Wolverine quelqu'un qui
a la capacité de vivre qui n'en a pas
forcément envie je ca  n mettre fin à ton
éternité te rendre mortel ce qu'ils
m'ont fait ce que je suis ne peut pas être défait n'en sois pas
si sûr
Wolverine sans son pouvoir de guérison c'est une
autre histoire sa chair est faible maintenant
qu'est-ce que tu caches qu'est-ce que ton
grand-père t'a dit  quand ils liront son
testament, vous n'êtes pas l'homme pour nous conduire à
tout, nous devenons la personne la plus puissante
au Japon qui révèle le
droit de Silversun, il veillera sur
le vieil homme pour toujours,
il n'est jamais tout à fait sûr à qui il peut faire confiance.
joue tous ces différents
niveaux face au Japon ancien et
moderne entre les ninjas et Viper
et les samouraïs argentés que vous voyez bien plus à
risque et plus d'un monstre que vous ne l'avez
jamais vu auparavant, donc vous êtes venu
combattre c'est inutile
nous sommes en infériorité numérique, ce sont tous les hommes que
vous avez amenés
genre de monstre êtes-vous le Wolverine
vous